few franchises have a concept as
evocative as the purge the allegory
heavy property puts forth the premise of
an annual 12-hour period in which all
crime in the US is legal an idea
introduced with the series first movie
in 2013 the fourth movie the first purge
takes audiences back to the first
experimental instance of what would
later become a violent tradition said in
the New York City borough of Staten
Island the horror thriller hybrid
provides the clearest look yet at the
beginnings of the purge as a national
institution if you're not sure that you
picked up on everything the movie was
putting down stay with us as we break
down the ending and thematic takeaways
of the first purge defend the
neighborhood act three of the first
purge turns into a full-on
action movie as drug kingpin Dmitry
storms the towers of the Park Hill
housing projects to protect his friends
on the 14th floor by this point the
movie has officially turned from a
citizen on citizen free-for-all into a
government sanctioned extermination
campaign as the International militia
hired by the nffa begins clearing the
building floor-by-floor it's dramatic
irony that the only defender of the
vulnerable people in the housing project
is the friendly neighborhood narcotic
salesman who apparently happens to spend
every moment away from his business
lifting weights eating protein and
getting insanely good at using firearms
far from the typical media portrayal of
a drug dealer Dmitri is a homegrown
Batman figure his neighborhoods wealthy
well-equipped
most capable defender unlike a hyper
right-wing government and ruling class
that is literally trying to kill the
neighborhood this businessman turned
warrior is an authority figure who
values his community and keeping people
safe he's not your typical protagonist
and it's one of the things that makes
this particular purge installment so
intriguing intentional extermination
after two acts worth of tension in the
streets the government takes the gloves
off for the movies brutal finale at this
point the undercurrent of class warfare
and exploitation that's informed the
whole series is revealed in all of its
ugliness as the purge is identified as a
tool for exterminating the lower class
the event isn't a solution to society's
problems but a scapegoating of society's
weakest with free passes going to the
forces and control that are actually to
blame in a country where the economic
divide between the upper and lower
classes has never been more dramatic
is a message that resonates in our very
real world the poor are often blamed for
their own circumstances instead of the
predatory forces that exploit them and
keep them down in the just slightly
heightened world of the purge they're
not just blamed for their own poverty
they're intentionally exterminated Lords
of war the nffa isn't just relying on
its private militia to exterminate the
poor in order to make sure that the
experimental first purge actually pops
off the government injects a massive
influx of heavy weaponry into the Staten
Island black market most of these
weapons are handily requisitioned by
Demitri staff who use the Arsenal for
their own counter-offensive against the
government-sponsored invaders this plot
turned speaks to a number of tactics
that have been used allegedly or not by
the US government as the first purge
establishes the nffa believes that death
needs to happen on a massive scale
during the experiment in order to create
the political capital for a national
purge to achieve that end they're
willing to covertly arm the population
with heavy artillery it's a fact that
the US government sends weapons all over
the place to aid with causes nations and
groups that it supports around the world
directly fueling conflicts for its own
benefit in the first purge the
government sends out arms to exterminate
its own people another instance of the
movie taking something real and adding a
sinister twist signs of violence the
first purge clearly wraps the government
and its allies in recognizable symbols
of white supremacy taking the races
undercurrent that's always been
associated with the purge and making it
explicit it's not just a class war the
nffa is gunning for it's a race war with
a Nazi s Commission it's no accident
that the fourth purge movie features a
cast according to producer james
demonaco that's 90% black because the
theme of white violence against black
communities is at the heart of what the
movies trying to convey the movie plays
with potent iconography to help spread
violence on Staten Island the government
lets in goons with red white and blue
KKK hoods evoking decades of history of
racist violence blue-eyed blonde-haired
government sanctioned militiamen wear
black face masks or dressed like SS
officers as they attack the Staten
Island community acts of violence in the
movie uncut
durably evoke real-life hate crimes with
attackers bearing torches and wearing
crosses that clearly evoke recognizable
hate symbols it's heavy stuff that the
movie doesn't always deploy gracefully
making for bracing moments that get way
too real be alright
the movie ends in fire as the showdown
in the Park Hill projects comes to a
violent c4 fuelled conclusion the end of
the fight just happens to coincide with
the end of the 12-hour experiment period
just like that the island is returned to
a state of relative calm after the
shootout Dmitry Naya Isaiah and Delores
joined the crowd outside in the light of
dawn reconnecting with the community
after the night of violence instead of
tearing each other apart as the nffa
attended the citizens defended each
other a moral victory if nothing else as
the movie ends the purge is over now to
paraphrase the movies final words it's
time to fight the movies hopeful ending
stands in contrast to what we know about
where the story is going the residents
of Staten Island don't succeed in
stopping the purge from spreading
nationwide and the tradition doesn't end
for years or potentially decades despite
this the movie concludes to the hopeful
strains of kendrick lamar's alright a
modern-day anthem of resolve and
resilience that's used now to represent
resistance no matter how many purges
happen in the future people will always
try to help each other and survive
people will always fight back in a
series this bleak that's a victory in
itself thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]